these dancing women are called the
celebrants of dominula dominula is the
village of windmills and here the
maidens dance heedlessly adorned with
blue fabrics and pink flowers but
there's something deeply wrong here for
one the women are wielding instruments
made out of bone designed to rake and
strip the Flesh of their Noble victims
but why skin these citizens of Lane Del
well further up the hill we find a
couple of celebrants venerating a
god-skinned apostle a member of a
heretical group that once served
destined death and skinned the very Gods
it follows that the women and their
skinning rituals have been inspired by
the godskin so why are they celebrating
well long ago the godskin lost a war to
Queen America and her golden order their
power over death was taken from them but
now their skinning rituals are being
performed on America's own citizens
right on America's own doorstep using
America's own crucifixes as maypoles to
be danced around you might be
celebrating too